how's it going red and welcome back to a
hellhole and we [ __ ] call Silent Hill
I hate this game
I'm not gonna lie I hate it in the way
that I don't even know where to go
[ __ ] are we going I guess we came from
north let's check out the music room I
want to see what the real Seagrove has
to say [ __ ] canonical
oh maybe we can don't count a cockroach
bad cockroach yeah that's right all
right you stay down [ __ ] man oh
I find your weak spot here our NEFAs
okay why do we have a high res that road
is croc maybe we can escape to the music
room there is no music room all right
here let's conquer just ah [ __ ] Oh Suzie
I don't have time for no temple Porter I
didn't know where the [ __ ] I'm going I
think that is right though cuz it's a
corridor isn't it that's a classroom the
[ __ ] am I
oh that room was locked oh [ __ ]
maybe the locker room no we've been in
the locker room we know what awaits in
the locker room let's try to hit keep on
heading north actually yeah let's do
that rez why I tell you why cuz you came
to decided to jungle ah I like it stop
reading
I got it site nice I came from North I'm
an idiot
all right let's go here let's go I just
go I'm sure it's really nice okay I can
never read this map well enough all
right uh let's go up boss up busting
your ass
turn out the light how oh [ __ ]
pity pie no gusta what's up with all
these whoa [ __ ] even the door sound
[ __ ] me up oh oh come on I'm on the
rooftop now Oh some blood car sighs what
are you doing here blood investigation
there's a hanging key it's just out of
reach do have something that we can use
for this maybe the pipe nope I thought
we could use the pipe what about the
ball can use it here what shut up
I will have nothing god dammit
well I found you what is this let's pull
this what am i doing right now
I have no idea if this is good or not I
mean of course I know what I'm doing oh
let's go hilarious yeah oh it's it
drains the hole maybe I the bar the bar
the bar the bar the power double they're
all sorry
alright let's plug the ball the ball
comes in place don't ya
hi patty I'm glad I can help you out
balls don't talk you didn't even have
him out seriously put the ball in the
hole put the ball in the hole but the
bowel and hole and then the key will
float up totally stole ameesha totally
stole that puzzle chocolate
not really I was kind of similar I guess
I don't
all right good job our house can count
on you all right
and if you go up about that
do you have to turn it off there please
some of the keys there now otherwise all
my happiness for nothing
take the key uh it went down the drain
don't this die okay okay
I'm Dom taking my ball back I'm pissed
the ball is stuffed inside the car
well let the funky go down the drain
shouldn't it go down here cuz we plugged
it no well I don't know let's check the
mat huh come on what are you looking at
it's a [ __ ] creepy alright fine I'm
going down
oh come on bedroom are you looking at
fine
alright no problem
Wow
I guess we can go in here alright
okay can't be open I think sir I can't
be open either and these are closed what
about this store it's locked
everything is live well why are we going
then look man I really can't get
anywhere over there I need to find the
drains oh hello
I need you yes take me side way a lot of
way you can take me anyway hello any
dead people in here all right Larry um
all right what's the plan here seriously
huh I have no idea
let's keep going
I guess go down and maybe there's like a
sewerage thing and we can find the key
there like don't worry
hey start seeing men's love the Amen we
need to run past this car line one lorry
oh we got night like don't die don't die
it seriously though don't die you know
but no yes
don't have time for your [ __ ] Larry I'm
not gonna have sex with you laddie chase
the skies are desperate [ __ ] up
cockroaches if this is like I'm gonna
cry all right I don't even know what's
up not this again
better be a cat this time around
oh good is nothing inside
how about all the blood there's their
period Locker now why would you do that
so she weighs a period
ah
little [ __ ]
ah they got me good how's a good one
okay I'll take that libraries m'kay
you little [ __ ] huh yeah little [ __ ]
you just had to do it that was a good
run that was a really good one I did not
in a million years expected no lie I'm
sick you cockroach are made seriously
ah [ __ ] me how do i okay have I have a
key now let's this is boomin
alright I gotta kill you no no don't you
touch me I'm not gonna die I'm not gonna
die that I'm not gonna die I'm not no
sir no sir look at that glad look at
that Larry
suck my dick laughing no one likes to
lay your tacos Armour is full up it
features oh I stomp your [ __ ] I'll give
a [ __ ]
alright let's look what kind of key
begun library all right voice library
donde está nublado
oh it's have it I call we can go that ah
we need to go to the classrooms
hopefully we don't run into any ladder
asses [ __ ] la race every day
Oh got your knock about dr. Locke how
about about doctor all right we need to
go over here yes and forward and then
library please don't be any lawyers in
here bang it's gotta be in here I'm
doing good progress thing like a bass
come here what's this
there's nothing oh hello what is making
those noises
what is making those [ __ ] noises I
just grabbed my first aid that's how I'm
[ __ ] me over no useful books huh one
of us a battery on this flashlight uh I
guess we can go to the library
wow you're like knocking on things in
here
oh there's a book here for me let's read
it ah Twilight hearing this the hunter
armed with a bow and arrow said I will
kill the Lizzy
hearing this the hunter armed with a bow
and arrows said I would kill the lizard
but upon mating his opponent he held
back taunting who's afraid of a reptile
at this the furious lizard hissed I will
swallow you up in a single detail then
you hear the huge creature attack doors
open wide this was what the man wanted
call me drawing his bow he shot into the
lasers gaping mouth effort Lee they are
afloat piercingly through the
defenseless mall and the lesson fell
down dead are they telling me this is
from an old fairy tale I remember these
reading as a kid it's pretty epic
are they hinting me to do something like
that because I'm not down to doing stuff
like that
I know here alright I'm just not cut out
for it
I don't look a bit like that okay I'll
try to kill the lizard all right now we
can pass through the hallway here oh i
think ye i lie
oh no I can go in this classroom
haha right I know you're in here okay
okay what is up with this room alright I
did not cheat
do we need to head downstairs so I think
I will cut to where I go downstairs all
right we're almost there
I didn't take that long no Larry's
please exactly this door all right there
should be a pipe here somewhere that put
down the key hopefully maybe here yeah
Jay - Fitz doesn't strike
whatever classroom okay all right oh I
know which classroom I know which
classroom ah all right
no let's log - [ __ ] I'll just [ __ ] go
over here then I breast I'm gonna have
ten steps in here like a fish if you
died subscribe every day
all right what is that
all right I have this yay Ali Harlan
Erica with a bear pit mouse [ __ ] up
why are they so heavy [ __ ] off hey why
is it so narrow
oh [ __ ] my face